well I used to say and I'm still
inclined to say occasionally that I hate
it that I hate the game of life I don't
really at least I don't anymore the
reason why I felt like that was that
whenever you know my name was mentioned
in respect of some mathematics it was
always the game of life and I don't
think the game of life was very very
interesting don't think it was worth all
that EFT and lots of other mathematical
things and so I found the game of life
was sort of overshadowing much more
important things and I did not like it
now well I'm getting old my capacity for
hatred is getting less I suppose and it
was an achievement and I'm quite proud
of this and I just want don't want to
talk about it all the time I'm sorry I
couldn't not ask you about it what is
the game of life this thing that is
you're stuck with now well will you be
able to focus on this yes I can focus on
that no problems have I got some coins
in my pocket casis I don't have you in
the game of life you sort of drop a
handful of nuts or counters or something
the rules are at any given time you've
got some of these things that are are
full that I'll call that life and some
of them that are empty and we'll call
that dead if you've got too many
neighbors oh yes the neighbours of a
cell are all the eight things nearest to
it if you've got too many neighbours you
die if you go four or more in other
words that's the exact definition of too
many you die of overcrowding probably
because there's not enough food in that
region but if you've only got one or no
live neighbors you die of isolation now
let's look this guy
is going to die of isolation and this
guy only has one neighbor to bet they're
both going to die but the other thing is
if you're dead at the moment but you've
got exactly three live neighbours you
see this guy as one two three live
neighbours out of the eight places next
time and so does this guy can you see it
got one two three so there's going to be
a happy event
next time two things are going to be
born here and here and these two are
going to die a muscle eat them this
guy's going to die and these things now
who were babies at the moment are going
to grow up there though they're
adolescents now that's got the slow next
time I'll just do it quickly it's going
to be somebody bought in here because he
has three live neighbours and somebody
born here the condition for giving birth
is that you have exactly three parents
as it seems rather unusual but it's not
really imitating the human life so to
speak it definitely isn't so the places
that I'm pointing to now are going to be
born and this one has four live
neighbors one two three four so he's
going to die and this one only has one
live neighbor so he's going to die this
guy dies of overcrowding and this guy
right next door dies of isolation so
they're going to die and the places
where my fingers are pointing who
doesn't be born with this configuration
this is the same shape as it was when I
started two moves ago but it's moved a
little bit and if you just follow it
it'll keep on moving like this
forevermore
it's what we called the glider I wish I
hadn't called it the glider because if
you look at this when you somebody's
programmed a machine for you it looks
more like an ant I wish I'd called it an
ant it just walks across the plane what
about game of London since that it's a
long time ago we proved everything about
it
namely we proved that it could do
arbitrary computations it could build
copies of itself which had interesting
properties could move across the plane
it's hard to say exactly easily to an
audience that doesn't actually
understand these things exactly how we
prove those I'm not entirely responsible
for that and when I first told it to
Martin Gardner who wrote the
mathematical games column in Scientific
American I advertised really I didn't
know that it would have these properties
I hoped it would and so I advertised for
a finite configuration which grew
indefinitely that was the simplest
testable instance of this sort of
ubiquity this universality and somebody
at MIT bill Gosper and few colleagues of
his came up with this thing called the
glider gun which emitted a glider every
30 moves and we played with that and in
the end succeeded in proving this
universality thing you know we called it
the game of life because it seemed in a
little bit well some of the ideas we had
were taken from real life you know if
you have if you have too many organisms
of your type in a given region you die
off because it isn't enough food for you
or something
if you've too few well you know it's
nice to have a few companions and if you
don't have companions you might as well
die I mean that's it and so on so the
basic rules are tremendous
simplification of the rules of sort of
real life very very simple organisms you
have the unpredictability of real life -
and and yet it all comes from very very
simple rules so I think that's why
people are interested you know who would
have thought well I thought but
typically one doesn't think that one can
get a decent simulate
of real living things in such a very
simple way mathematician won't be good
at various things and so on and in my
late 20s I hadn't achieved any of the
things that people were predicting and
so I call it my black period I started
to wonder you know whether it was all
nonsense whether I was not a good
mathematician after all and so on